but the animal kingdom also has its fair
share of show-offs like Norman the dog
it's like there is a little person
inside and stuff dog outfit peddling on
this bike I find it a bit weird
the dog he's on a bike what's not to
like about that
doorman bike good
we asked Norman who's a French sheepdog
how he did it but he's a dog even our
experts don't understand him so we asked
his human instead good boy I took about
three years for him to learn to ride the
bike from start to finish but mostly it
was because we didn't have a bicycle
that fit him as he was growing we need
to keep changing bicycles and modifying
things good boy stay once he was
full-sized we worked on it about a year
before he was really pedaling on his own
good job very good training some dogs to
fetch a ball is hard work but riding a
light how's that done the dog has
learned how to do this step by step and
what happens is the dog will have been
taught to do the first name maybe just
hop on that bike and we'll get a
positive reinforcement some food treats
or some love and this is how dogs are
trained this is how they learn to do
tricks
so the moment he does what I like I'll
click a dog clicker and give him a treat
after that way he knows that's the exact
behavior I wanted and the treats coming
good boy and that's what scientists call
operant conditioning and Norman clearly
has the ability to learn and execute a
complex series of instructions over time
good oh you got it but that's not the
only thing you can do using the same
training techniques he's able to ride a
scooter good job
there you go good and play the piano
well sort of
you